While we're recording these, actually we thought it wasn't a very challenging example
and then we got it wrong about 4 times, but the correct answer here is that these three lines
take 11 time steps to execute.
The first line is free as in the first quiz and the second line is actually why we had
to count a few times until we all got it right.
This line here is executed 6 times--once for s=5
and then s is decreased by 1 each time this line down here is executed.
So, s starts out as 5, 4, 3, 2, 1 and 0, which means this line here is executed 6 times
whereas this line down here is only executed 5 times because once s is equal to 0
this line here is not executed anymore, which makes for a total of 11 time steps.